dr Georg Hofmann
Frau Ministerin ich würde sie um ihre
Worte aussuchen
ja vielen Dank
und Herren
bereits zu meinen zu Beginn meiner
Amtszeit vor über drei Jahren habe ich
zu unserem heeresgeschichtlichen Museum
gesagt dass ihr dieses auf neue Beine
stellen müssen das HGM ist ein national
und international gesehen wohl eines
einzigartig es ist nicht nur das
älteste der älteste Museumsbau Wiens
sondern es verschmelzen Militär und
Kriegsgeschichte Technik und
Naturwissenschaft Kunst und Architektur
zu etwas ganz
einzigartigem zu einem einzigartigen
ganzen aber faktum ist auch dass es in
den letzten Jahrzehnten leider viele
Versäumnisse gegeben hat das haben nicht
zuletzt die Berichte von zwei
Kommissionen und natürlich auch der
Rechnungshofbericht ganz deutlich
aufgezeigt viele der in diesen Berichten
aufgezeigten Versäumnisse sind nicht
unbedingt ganz aktuelle sondern sie
gehen teilweise bis ins Jahr 19 55
zurück es ist meinem Vorgänger Thomas
Stallinger nicht zuletzt zu verdanken
dass er mit der ersten Kommission den
Beginn gesetzt hat und ich habe dann
auch gleich nach meiner Amtszeit
entschieden eine erweiterte zweite
unabhängige Kommission mit
internationalen Expertinnen und Experten
einzusetzen zu Evaluierung des HGM unter
der Führung von Professor Dr Wolfgang
Muchitsch damit dieser Prozess auch so
breit wie möglich aufgestellt wird ja
wir haben vor einiger Zeit im Ressort
begonnen die empfohlenen Maßnahmen des
Rechnungshofes auch umzusetzen wir sind
hier sehr weit von den 90 Empfehlungen
des Rechnungshofes ist bei einer ein
Drittel schon umgesetzt ja und natürlich
auch die der Kommissions Berichte es
gibt hausinterne Projekte im Ministerium
die sich mit den Grundlagen und auch mit
der Einführung eines
Qualitätsmanagements im HGM befasst
haben ja und das zusätzliche Maßnahme
haben einen ständigen wissenschaftlichen
Beirat mit wirklich namhaften nationalen
und internationalen Expertinnen und
Experten für das HGM eingerichtet
zunächst wie gesagt und Führung von
Professor Muchitsch schon seit heuer
unter der Führung von
Universitätsprofessor Magister dr
wolfgang Müller dieser Beirat war es
auch der bei der Personalauswahl des
neuen direkt das mit eingebunden war und
es ist mir persönlich auch wichtig dass
auch die künftige Führung des Museums
auf diesen wissenschaftlichen Beirat
hört mit diesem auf wissenschaftlicher
Ebene ganz eng auch zusammen arbeitet
wir haben auch budgetäre
Herausforderungen wir werden 4,3
Millionen Euro zur Modernisierung
Neugestaltung und Digitalisierung der
Ausstellungen investieren ja aber vor
allem und das ist der Grund der heutigen
Pressekonferenz wir haben die Führung
des Museums neu ausgeschrieben ich
persönlich bin davon überzeugt dass mit
einem
Neubeginn auch eine neue Führung
notwendig ist ein Neubeginn das heißt
immer auch Mut zu haben Mut zur
Veränderung zu haben alte Pfade zu
verlassen und neue Brücken zu bauen ich
bin überzeugt davon dass wir mit Dr
Hoffmann die richtige Wahl getroffen
haben unser Museum in ein modernes
Zeitalter zu führen er wird Ihnen dann
im Anschluss erläutern wohin der Weg
unseres militärmuseums führen soll wir
haben nun mit dr Hoffmann einen neuen
Direktor des Museums bekommen wir haben
aber noch etwas neu gestaltet mit der
rechtswissenschaftlerin Magister
Stefanie brachersdorfer haben wir eine
neue Funktion besetzt der abteilungs-
Reiterhof Frau Dr Christoph ratschek zur
Seite gestellt werden der eine
langjährige Erfahrung und Expertise hat
was die wissenschaftliche
militärhistorische Gestaltung des
Museums anbelangt ein paar Worte sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren was die Auswahl
der neuen Führung des HGM anbelangt wir
haben das mit äußerster Sorgfalt gemacht
selbstverständlich nach dem
ausschreibungsgesetz durchgeführt der
Bewerber die Bewerber mussten neben den
üblichen Unterlagen wie Lebenslauf
Motivationsschreiben und Nachweisen auch
ein ganz Faches spezifisches Konzept
vorlegen dass dann durch die
begutachtungskommission und auch den
wissenschaftlichen Beirat beurteilt
wurde sind ein Herings durchgeführt
worden und auch externe Gutachten
eingeholt worden ja noch intensiver
Überlegung und auch durch sich dieser
Gutachten sowohl der
Bewertungskommission als auch das
Beirates und auch durch die externe
personalberatungsfirma habe ich mich für
Dr Georg Hoffmann als geeigneten
Kandidaten für die Führung des Museums
entschieden er hat bei allen drei
genannten Gutachten den höchstmöglichen
bewertungsgrad aufgewiesen dr Hoffmann
ist ein zukunftsorientierter
Wissenschaftler mit einem Verständnis
für museale Gestaltung als solche ist
der bekannt als Militär und
Zeithistoriker als
Ausstellungskurator und auch
milizoffizier bringt doch dr Hoffmann
die Pforten Voraussetzungen für die
Führung unseres Museums mit ja neben der
Ausschreibung des Direktors konnten wir
eben zusätzlich mit dem
beamtenministerium auch eine neue
Strukturierung der kaufmännischen
Abteilung erreichen und eine neue
Funktion schaffen die abteilungs-
übernommen wird sie wird eben dr
Hoffmann als stellvertretende Leiterin
in allen wirtschaftlichen Belangen
unterstützen das insbesondere auch unter
dem Aspekt dass sie sehr viele
Erfahrungen gesammelt hat nicht nur im
öffentlichen Dienst sondern auch in der
Privatwirtschaft ich freue mich dass sei
an dieser Stelle auch gesagt dass wir
erstmals erstmals eine Frau auch an der
Spitze des Museums installieren konnten
sondern es ist uns dazu auch eines
gelungen dass wir Wissenschaft und
Wirtschaft die kaufmännischen Belange
des Museums auch ganz klar drinnen das
war ja auch eine der Anregungen des
Rechnungshofes dadurch kann sich daher
Direktor Hoffmann dann voll und ganz der
wissenschaftlichen Weiterentwicklung
unseres jahresgeschichtlichen Museums
widmen die wirtschaftlichen Belange
davon bin ich überzeugt werden auf eine
professionelle Grundlage gestellt und
ich glaube damit ist der Weg für
modernes und ein zeitgemäßes Museum
beschritten
wir sind gemeinsam fest entschlossen und
das ist auch notwendig dass wir das HGM
in ruhigere Fahrwasser bringen wir haben
uns das wirklich sehr gut angesehen wir
haben genau geprüft wir haben einige
Jahre drei Jahre wirklich hart gemeinsam
nicht zuletzt auch mit der Kommission
gearbeitet und sind jetzt auf einem
wirklich sehr guten Weg dass unser HGM
zu einem modernen Museum der Zukunft
auch wird danke schön
danke sehr ich darf nun den neuen
Direktor und Leiter des Heeres
geschichtlichen Museums Herrn Dr Georg
Hofmann um seine Worte suchen
sehr geehrte Frau Bundesminister sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren ich darf mich
zunächst bedanken Frau Bundesminister
für das Vertrauen sie in mich setzen und
überantwortung der Leitung des
jahresgeschichtlichen Museums
ich trete diese Aufgabe mit Demut und
Respekt an auch mit großer Freude denn
das Heeresgeschichtliche Museum ist
eines der ältesten eines der größten
historischen Museen die wir haben auch
im europäischen Kontext und genau
gemessen an der Sammlung auch eines der
reichhaltigsten eines mit dem größten
Potenzial ich bin mir der Verantwortung
dieser Aufgabe durchaus bewusst nicht
zuletzt aufgrund der Diskussion die ist
schon länger gibt und und das Museum
auch
davorwürfe letztlich auch dem
öffentlichen Eindruck eine Stillstandes
und genau hier möchte ich ansetzen und
gemeinsam mit dem Team des
jahresgeschichtlichen Museums eine
Weiterentwicklung einleiten die setzt
sich unter drei Schlagworte Schlagworte
lauten Modernisierung
Öffnung und Diskussion
das ist gewissermaßen die Zielsetzung
die wir uns geben
ich bringe aufgrund meiner beruflichen
Erfahrungen hier mehrere Ebenen ein ich
bin Historiker
Militärhistoriker mit Schwerpunkt 20
Jahrhundert noch einmal konkret
Schwerpunkt Militärgeschichte und
Nationalsozialismus
ausstellungskurater mit museumsexperte
waren Aufbau des Hauses der Geschichte
beteiligt eine der modernsten
museumsformen die wir aktuell kennen und
ich habe eine Verbundenheit zum
österreichischen Bundesheer nicht nur
als milizoffizier sondern auch in meiner
letzten Verwendung als
wissenschaftlicher Leiter der
Kooperation zwischen dem
österreichischen Bundeswehr und derzeit
Gedenkstätte Mauthausen hier ging es
letztlich und ich Schaffung und Hebung
eines historischen Bewusstseins als
Soldatinnen und Soldaten Stärkung
demokratischer Werte in der Gesellschaft
und damit auch letztlich um Impulse im
Bereich der geistigen Landesverteidigung
ist der Ausgangspunkt für mich
wichtig ist ist in dieser
Weiterentwicklung des
heeresgeschichtlichen Museums ich sehe
jetzt zwei Säulen seit wesentliche
Säulen der Weiterentwicklung und das
Museums der eine Seite lautet es ist
eine historisches Museum des
Bundesministeriums für
Landesverteidigung die zweite Säule es
ist ein Museum der Militärgeschichte und
von hier aus werden wir die
Entwicklungen beginnen und die
Weiterentwicklungen beginnen die Vision
die ich hier haben die ich gemeinsam mit
dem Team weiterentwickeln möchte möchte
ich zwei Punkte aufgreifen das eine das
heeresgeschichtlichen Museum aus
modernes Militärgeschichte Museum
das bedeutet es steht die Verbindung
zwischen Gesellschaft und Militär im
Vordergrund
im Fokus dabei der Mensch der Mensch aus
Akteur in der Geschichte der Mensch das
Teil von Gesellschaften die sich
erinnern auch das ist ein wesentlicher
Punkt
Multiperspektivität Diversität sind
dabei Leitbilder automatisch
die Relevanz einer moderne
Militärgeschichte zeigt sich letztlich
auf tragische Art und Weise nicht
zuletzt durch aktuelle Ereignisse durch
den durch den Angriffskrieg Russlands
auf die Ukraine unter anderem die auch
historisch hinterlegt ist
wir werden uns das bedeutet es natürlich
innerhalb des Museums die
Weiterentwicklung auch in den
Darstellungsformen in der musealen
Display unter anderem bauliche Maßnahmen
also gibt es eine große Palette die wir
im Team gemeinsam auch konzeptioneller
Arbeiten werden die zweite Vision die
ich habe ist das jahresgeschichtlichen
Museum als Diskussionsort
Diskussion ist nicht nur gemessen und
aktuellen Diskussion dieses aus meiner
Sicht zu führen denn das ist die Aufgabe
eines Museums eine gesellschaftliche
Diskussion
ich sehe jetzt aber weiter die
Diskussion muss ins Museum geholt werden
die muss Teil des Displays sein und Teil
eines modernen museumsverständnisses ich
sehe es aber auch noch weitergelernt als
Anker innerhalb des österreichischen
Bundesheeres denn diese Diskussion diese
Diskussionsort ist auch ein
diskussionsrat für Soldatinnen und
Soldaten auch für die Formen einer
Reflexion Selbstreflexion die letztlich
auch das Haus selber betrifft noch hier
verstehe ich Museum durchaus auch als
Beitrag zur geistigen Landesverteidigung
das ist der Anspruch den wir stellen
diese modernes Militärgeschichte Museum
dass ich als diskussionsrat begreift
das Militärgeschichte im
gesamtgesellschaftlichen Rahmen sieht
das verknüpft ist mit anderen
Forschungs- und museumseinrichtungen und
eingebettet ist in den
museumstheoretischen Diskurs da findet
die Weiterentwicklung statt
das ist der Weg hin dass wir dem
jahresgeschichtlichen Museum auch wieder
die Bedeutung geben die im eigentlich
Kraft seiner Sammlung und Kraft seiner
Themen zusteht wir werden uns hier
entlang der Punkte des
rechnungsberichtes Vorarbeiten auch
da Kommissionen und in Abstimmung mit
dem wissenschaftlichen Beirat ein
wichtiger für mich ganz wichtiger erster
Schritt betrifft aber das Team selbst
das Team steht im Vordergrund
in jeder Hinsicht ich sehe meine Aufgabe
vor allem darin dass das Team Sicherheit
bekommt dass es genug
Handlungsräume bekommt um kreativ
arbeiten zu können und das inkludiert
natürlich auch eine weiter
fortschreitende Professionalisierung
hier wurden schon Schritte gesetzt nenne
den Qualitätsmanagementprozess der
aufgesetzt ist ein Meilenstein aus
meiner Sicht es war vor allem die
Schaffung einer neuen Stelle und das ist
schon erwähnt worden
die Abteilungsleitung für Administration
und Museumsbetrieb wo wir mit Frau
magersdorfer eine wirklich Expertin
gewinnen konnten das freut mich
besonders es ist nämlich auch ein
Schritt hin zu einem weiteren Ziel dass
ich mir setze und das betrifft letztlich
auch die Hebung des Anteils von Frauen
im Museum
ich darf schließen vielleicht mit einem
3-liedrigen Appell geht auch eine Frau
Bundesminister diese Weiterentwicklung
des heeresgeschichte Museums nach
Kräften zu unterstützen
es ist auch die Aufforderung an Museen
Forschungseinrichtungen zur
Zusammenarbeit zu gemeinsamen Arbeit in
der Zukunft und es ist letztlich genau
in diesem
weiterentwicklungsprozess auch die Bitte
an der Öffentlichkeit um Geduld
herzlichen Dank
danke sehr bevor wir nun zur
dekretsübergabe schreiten und danach zu
Einzelinterviews übergehen dürfte ich
nun eine Frage Runde eröffnen und
ersuchungen Handzeichen als Fragen sind
bitte das Medium und den Namen und dann
die Frage zu stellen guten Morgen Sonja
harter von der Arbeit ich habe zuerst
eine Frage an die Frau Ministerin der
Rechnungshofbericht und die
evaluierungsberichte waren ja aus dem
Jahr 2020 warum hat es bis Mitte 2022
gedauert bis sie den Posten das Direktor
endlich ausgeschrieben haben und dann
Sie Herr Hoffmann möchte ich fragen
diese Modernisierung wird die bei
laufenden Betrieb stattfinden werden Sie
einzelne Abteilungen schließen was sind
da ihre Pläne danke
ja ich glaube
gerade in Anbetracht dessen der Film
Versäumnisse ich angesprochen habe
teilweise ja in die 50er Jahre auch
zurückgehen weiß notwendig sich sehr
intensiv damit zu beschäftigen das eine
war der Rechnungshofbericht dessen
Umsetzung durchaus auch noch einiges an
Zeit in Anspruch nehmen wird das zweite
war die intensive Zusammenarbeit auch
der Verantwortlichen meines Hauses mit
der wissenschaftlichen Kommission und es
war mir auch ganz wichtig diesen Prozess
der Neuausschreibung transparent
durchzuführen sehr umfangreich
durchzuführen nicht nur nach den
Vorgaben des ausschreibungsgesetzes
durchzuführen sondern auch eine
zusätzliche eine zusätzliche externe
Beratungen externes Gutachten noch
einzuholen und ich bin jetzt überzeugt
dass wir nach diesem ohne Zweifel
längerem Weg auf einem guten Weg in die
Zukunft sind
die Modernisierung des Museums wird
konzeptionell erarbeitet werden mit dem
Team das heißt auf Basis dieser Konzepte
werden wir dann Schritte beschließen in
Abgleich mit dem Ministerium und auch in
Abstimmung mit dem Beirat das heißt
jetzt ist es noch zu früh genau diese
Entscheidungen zu treffen die werden
dann zu gegebener Zeit gemacht werden
immer auf Basis eines Konzept eines
arbeitenden Konzepts
Stefan weiß vom Standard Fragen die Frau
Ministerin der scheidende Direktor der
wird jetzt bei ihnen im Ministerium ein
neues Amt begleiten jetzt ist es Gerücht
auch aufgetaucht dass möglicherweise das
HGM irgendwann auch dieser Abteilung
dann angegliedert werden könnte und
somit der
entscheidende Direktor erst recht wieder
irgendwie
Befugnisse haben könnte über das HGM
können Sie das definitiv ausräumen
dementieren oder kommentieren
vielen Dank für diese Frage weil es mir
die Möglichkeit gibt und sie haben sehr
angesprochen das sind so viele Gerüchte
im Umlauf und bleiben wir einmal bei den
Fakten ein Faktum ist das Dr Christian
Ordner als Museumsdirektor durchaus auch
trotz der Berechtigten Kritikpunkte
viele Erfolge auch einfahren hat können
für das Museum wenn man an die
Besucherzahlen denkt auch an zahlreiche
auf in den Medien an Vorträge in der
Öffentlichkeit auch denkt dennoch es hat
der berechtigte Kritik ohne Zweifel auch
gegeben es hat auch die einen oder
anderen
Mobbing-Vorwürfe gegeben denen wir
selbstverständlich von den zuständigen
Abteilungen meines Hauses auch
entsprechend nachgegangen sind aber ein
Faktum ist auch dass wir das
beamtendienstrechtsgesetz einzuhalten
haben und das ist mitunter auch einer
der Gründe warum interimistisch ein
dementsprechender bewerteter
Arbeitsplätze
zugewiesen werden musste nichts anderes
ist bis dato passiert und der
Zusammenhang mit dem Museum um das auch
noch einmal ganz ganz genau zu
beantworten ich wüsste nicht wo es da
einen Zusammenhang auch geben sollte
vielleicht sollte man die eine oder
andere Aussage eines blauen
personalvertreters den Fakten gegen
gegenüberstellen danke
Niklas leicher ORF Radio trotzdem gibt
es jetzt an der Anwendung von Herrn
Ortner zur zum Leiter des Instituts für
Strategie und Sicherheitspolitik massive
Kritik es wird eine Ausschreibung der
Leitungsfunktion gefordert werden sie
dem Nachkommen ja das ist ja
selbstverständlich klar dass wir uns
dann das
ausschreibungsgesetz auch halten da
steht ja außer Frage dass eine ist das
beamtendienstrecht dass es eben
notwendig macht eine dementsprechend
bewertete Stelle auch zuzuweisen
internistisch und alles was eine
Neuausschreibung anbelangt dann werden
wir selbstverständlich Nachkommen noch
einmal wer sich dieses Institut näher
angeschaut hat wer auch noch sieht dass
wir gerade in unserem Ressort damit
beschäftigt sind sehr vieles neu
aufzustellen denn wird auch nicht
entgangen sein dass er
selbstverständlich all unsere Institute
auch einer neuen Bewertung unterziehen
müssen wie so vieles in diesem Haus das
ist nicht nur
Mitarbeiter neuen Sicherheitslage
geschuldet sondern auch einer
Organisationsreform des Hauses
geschuldet daher selbstverständlich wird
Dr CHRISTIAN ORTNER entsprechend den
beamtendienstgesetzlichen Bestimmungen
interimistisch eine Stelle in der
Landesverteidigungsakademie begleiten
aber ausschreiben werden wir
selbstverständlich wenn das
ausschreibungsgesetz das auch vorsieht
eine letzte Frage
Tiroler Tageszeitung sie haben das ist
elegant nicht beantwortet die Frage des
Kollegen wird ausgeschrieben ja oder
nein dieser Posten das ist die erste
Frage die zweite Frage die ich
eigentlich stellen wollte sie hat direkt
dass sie kennen ja das Museum wo wollen
sie beginnen also was ist der erste
Punkt wo sie sagen da müssen wir
unbedingt etwas ändern modernisieren und
dann die dritte Frage gibt es für die
Modernisierung auch Geld
ich freue mich dass Sie dass das elegant
bezeichnet normal nach
selbstverständlich wenn es diese
Funktion der Führungsfunktion eines
Instituts noch gibt dann wird es
selbstverständlich ausgeschrieben werden
ich glaube das habe ich ganz klar gesagt
wenn es diese Position noch gibt dann
wird die selbstverständlich
entsprechende Bestimmungen
ausgeschrieben das was jetzt passiert
ist ist das was sie in einem Ressort
ungefähr pro Tag zigmal passiert nämlich
dass man eben den entsprechenden
gesetzlichen Bestimmungen nachkommt sie
müssen sie das ja so vorstellen das
landet ja nicht als auf meinem
Schreibtisch da wäre ja unserem Herrn
Hofrat dem Leiter der präsidentale
shavania durchaus Fahrt wenn ich das
alles alleine erledigen würde das ist
eine den Beamten man muss ja auch eines
sehen
das Beamtendienst recht mein das müsste
man den Vizekanzler vielleicht noch
genauer fragen aber das gibt ja vor das
gibt dir vor dass man als Dienstgeber
auch eine Fürsorgepflicht hat die es
nicht zulässt dass eben gerade Beamte
ins Bodenlose fallen der ist die
Formulierung ja auch so gewählt eine
entsprechend bewertete Stelle auch
zuzuteilen und noch einmal ganz klar
wenn es was zum ausschreiben gibt dann
werden wir das tun so wenn der
Vergangenheit auch ich halte
selbstverständlich alle Bestimmungen wie
halten alle Bestimmungen ein sowohl das
ausschreibungsgesetzes als auch das
beamtendienstrechtsgesetzes
selbstverständlich gerade angesprochen
die 4,3 Millionen Euro die entsprechend
dem Gesetz zum einen in die
Modernisierung fallen werden zum anderen
alles was die Digitalisierung auch
anbelangt aber das ist ja die Folge
dessen wie das Konzept dann eben
ausschaut aber im Budget ist
selbstverständlicher dieser Betrag eben
fürs erste vorgesehen ich möchte Herrn
Dr Hoffmann hier auch noch mal die
Möglichkeit geben die Frage zu
beantworten danach würden wir aufgrund
der fortgeschrittenen Zeit zu den die
krebsverleihungen kommen und im
Nachhinein gibt es noch die Möglichkeit
dann einzeln Interviews wo etwaige
Fragen dann noch beantwortet werden
könnten Herr Dr Hoffmann bitte die
ersten Schritte das das sage ich
wirklich auch so deutlich die ersten
Schritte richten sich auf die Arbeit mit
dem Team das heißt wir werden im Team
Dinge festlegen und Weiterentwicklungen
festlegen
wo setzt man konkrete Museum an da gibt
es zwei Linien die eines natürlich auch
eine bauliche Erneuerung den einzelnen
Ausstellung notwendig ist und die zweite
Linie ist eine in sicher und da ist
natürlich eh kein Geheimnis dass mir
besonders der Bereich Republik und
Diktatur am Herzen liegt
ich glaube da war noch eine Frage
eine Frage zu einer anderen Sache hätte
ich noch zum fliegerhaus bromowski da
kommt die denkmalkalmission zu dem
Schluss dass dieser umbenannt werden
sollte aufgrund der Rolle von Herrn
bromowski in den Februar kämpfen 1934
werden sie dieser Empfehlung nachkommen
alle empfehl die wir von den
militärhistorischen Kommissionen
erhalten und die liegt mir im konkreten
Fall noch nicht vor werden wir ganz
genau prüfen aber inhaltlich ist das
auch etwas Gutes weil inhaltlich in
dieser Sache er Direktor glaube ich sehr
gut auch informiert ist und auch gerne
etwas sagen wir dazu
ja also das ist ein ein Antrag der
geprüft wird bzw auch in der
militärischen Denkmalkommission es geht
hier ganz konkret um einen
österreich-ungarischen Flieger des
Ersten Weltkrieges der dann in den
Februar kämpfen unmittelbar mit seinem
Flugzeug beteiligt war das beginnen die
Forschungen tatsächlich erst da ist noch
nicht allzu viel bekannt das heißt hier
muss man natürlich wissenschaftlich noch
prüfen auf Basis der wissenschaftlichen
Prüfung der entsprechenden Schritte
einleiten
ich bedanke mich für die Frage und würde
jetzt zur dekretsübergabe schreiten und
darf die Frau Ministerin den Herrn Dr
Hofmann zu meiner Rechten
9 des bundesministeriumgesetzes 1986
Bundesgesetzblatt Nummer 76 mit
Wirksamkeit von 15 Februar 2023 mit der
Leitung des heeresgeschichtlichen
Museums damit sind sie gemäß
1948 in der geltenden Fassung mit der
Wirksamkeit von 15 Februar 2023
berechtigt die verwendungsbezeichnung
Direktor des heeresgeschichtlichen
Museums
grundsätzlich sind mit meiner besten
Glückwünschen in Kenntnis herzlichen
Glückwunsch
wirtschaftlichen Angelegenheiten Frau
Magister Stefanie brachersdorfer
ebenfalls auf die Bühne bieten
ich betreue Sie gemäß
Bundesministerium Gesetzes 1986
Bundesgesetzblatt Nummer 76 mit
Wirksamkeit von 15 Februar 2023 mit der
Leitung der Abteilung Administration und
Betrieb im jahresgeschichtlichen Museum
damit einhergeht dass sie gemäß
Paragraph 7 einverbindung mit Paragraph
67 Absatz 2 des Vertragsbediensteten
Gesetzes 1948 in der geltenden Fassung
mit Wirksamkeit von
oder 2023 berechtigt sind die
verwendungsbezeichnung Rating zu führen
ich darf Sie davon in Kenntnis setzen
verbunden mit meinen allerbesten
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren ich
erkläre die Pressekonferenz für beendet
und wir gehen jetzt über zu den
einzelnen Interviews